le palais de la découverte rouvre ses
portes et depuis son inauguration en
ce lieu situé juste à côté des champs
elysées a toujours gardé la même
ambition vulgariser les sciences
ce temple de la science fondamentale
ouvert à tous où chacun peut contempler
en s'instruisant de manière vivante les
conquêtes de l'esprit humain dans tous
les domaines de la science
ici pas de collection derrière des
cadres mais des expériences
le but montrer la science en train de se
faire bien loin d'un musée classique
comme l'expliqué son directeur on ne
peut pas dire que le poney de découverte
soit un musée on pourrait dire si l'état
s'il collectionne quelque chose il
collectionne des idées et des idées
qu'ils mettent en valeur qu'ils
présentent
il présente avec des expériences des
expériences scientifiques pour chaque
expérience des médiateurs qui explique y
montre et le visiteur devient un cobaye
humain comme ici en 1981
[Musique]
le chercheur qu'à l'extérieur être
acteur de l'expérience c'est une formule
qui fonctionne
de quoi narguer un peu depuis 50 ans le
palais mise sur l'animation scientifique
un succès constant envier même par les
américains près de 650 mille visiteurs
en 1985
les années passent et la science évolue
le palais s'adapte à ces changements
par exemple dans les années 90 un
atelier permettait d'apprendre le
fonctionnement du tout nouvel internet
mais il y avait aussi des expositions
expliquant le clonage ou la couche
d'ozone
nous pensons que l'évolution de la
science qui se complexifie qui
s'approfondit la rend peut-être de plus
en plus éloignés du grand public
c'est cette question que nous voulons
aborder en plus des expositions
permanentes le palais accueille des
expositions temporaires souvent
impressionnante mais toujours avec
l'idée originelle rendre accessible le
savoir buts quand même des expressions
période découverte c'est de rendre ça le
plus pédagogique possible notamment à
destination des enfants mais les parents
sont pas aux laissés pour compte
le palais rouvre ses portes pour
seulement six mois
car ensuite il sera fermé pour cause de
travaux de rénovation pendant au moins
deux ans alors si vous voulez vous faire
électrifié c'est maintenant
[Musique]